ces hommes ces femmes-là ceux dont je
parle à l'instant ceux qui représentent
la grande masse des étrangers qui vivent
sur notre territoire sont assurément
beaucoup plus patriotes et beaucoup plus
loyaux à la France que tous ces émigrés
fiscaux qui continuent à bénéficier d'un
laxisme coupable vous l'avez compris
notre vision des choses est à mil000
lieu de celle que défend la majorité
sénatoriale et le gouvernement nous
sommes à la fois en désaccord avec votre
con stat de départ et en désaccord par
conséquent avec toutes les mesures qui
en découlent en effet toutes les mesures
qui ont été votées en commission des
lois visent en réalité à aggraver le
projet initial présenté par le
gouvernement c'est la limitation du
droit du sol c'est la limitation du
regroupement familial ce qui est
d'ailleurs totalement contradictoire
avec l'objectif d'intégration car il va
bien falloir m'expliquer comment un
étranger qui vient en France peut
s'intégrer dès lors qu'il n'a pas la
possibilité
de vivre en famille et c'est par
ailleurs la remise en cause de l'aide
médicale d'État au fond partant de
l'idée que l'immigré est une menace vous
déployez une stratégie une stratégie qui
consiste à penser que vous réduirez les
flux migratoires en dégradant les
conditions d'accueil de ceux qui
viennent chercher refuse chez nous c'est
totalement faux d'abord parce que depuis
des années maintenant les conditions
d'accueil de ceux qui viennent chez nous
ont déjà été considérablement dégradés
et ça n'a en aucun cas conduit à ce que
les flux se tarissent ensuite parce que
le faible taux de recours de toute une
série d'aides dont pourrai bénéficier
les immigrés qui viennent sur notre
territoire prouve bien que les gens ne
viennent pas pour des
aides